The David Pakman show subreddit is now approaching
15,000 subscribers.
I hope you will find it at David pacman.com/reddit
a number of posts including this one about
the Tulsi Gabber Dave Rubin interview, which
I have not talked about on the show.
A user named Hugger for you says in light
of Tulsi Gabber.
His appearance on the Ruben report where she
claims the other dems are essentially pushing
for open borders.
Here are everyone's actual stated positions
and this post links to a very, very detailed
Wikipedia entry that confirms the Democratic
candidates are not for open borders.
I'll be honest, I saw about a quarter of that
interview, I think it was about 70 minutes.
I must've watched about 15 and I was thinking
of doing a story on the show about it, but
I honestly, I was so disgusted with it that
I couldn't sit through it all in order to
compile the the best or or really the worst
moments for you.
I would check it out if I were you, but I'm
not.
Uh, it's just really, really bad between the
horribly right-wing framed questions and the
even worse answers from Tulsa Gabbert it's
just, it's just bad and I encourage you to
watch it, but I'm not going to be covering
it on the program.
Also from the David Pakman show, sub Reddit,
has David Been Too soft on Elizabeth Warren
lately?
Some jerk 27 says, is it just mere, as David
not been criticizing Much Elizabeth Warren
lately, he seems to be very much ignoring
her flaws such as her not having enough political
courage to fight for her policies, not being
willing to challenge the establishment and
lead a true political revolution, not being
hard on medicare for all.
And of course, her foreign policy, Warren
is a watered down version of Sanders.
We even saw her kissing up to party insiders
behind closed doors.
David Pakman seems to be silent about all
of this.
Oh No, it's not that I'm silent on it.
It's that at the very beginning I told you
that although on Policy Bernie and Warren
ended up in similar places.
You need to understand that Warren's origins,
not oranges, but her origins are much more
establishment than Bernie's and I, I've been
ahead of this.
It's not that I'm ignoring it, it's that I've
been telling you about this for a year or
longer at this point in time.
Um, make sure you're subscribed to the subreddit@davidpacman.com
slash red dit it nearly 15,000 subscribers.
It is one of the largest independent progressive
media sub reddit communities, uh, out there.
I Dunno, in the world, I guess the world is
hard to say.
Certainly from American independent progressive
media for sure.
David pakman.com/reddit